Una fecha: el 23 de junio de 2016. Ese
día se produjo un acontecimiento que
hizo temblar los cimientos de toda
Europa. Por primera vez un país miembro
de la Unión Europea,
decidía romper y largarse del club.
Desde entonces fuera del Reino Unido hay
un gran consenso sobre qué es lo que va
a ocurrir; no dejamos de escuchar que las
consecuencias del Brexit serán
terribles para este país: crisis,
desempleo, la City está acabada,
Londres no volverá a pintar nada en el
mundo, etcétera, etcétera, etcétera.
- "La caída de la libra y la inestabilidad
que se puede generar puede provocar un
empobrecimiento de las personas que
viven en Gran Bretaña respecto al resto del mundo".
Y luego también están las
amenazas de la Unión Europea, una
organización por cuya reacción más
que una institución política aparece
mi novio celoso al que acaban de dejar
Vale, Reino Unido a decidido largarse,
pero al fin y al cabo son libres de
hacerlo ¿no os parece? Sí, yo también
entiendo reacciones como las de la
Unión Europea pero no las comparto para
nada ¿Para qué tantas amenazas? ¿No será
mejor tratar de negociar y alcanzar un
acuerdo que beneficie a las dos partes?
Sí, sí, sé que algunos dicen que o se le da un
escarmiento a Reino Unido o puede que
otros países decidan seguir sus pasos
pero.. entonces ¿la intención es dar miedo
para que nadie más se atreva a
cuestionar a la Unión Europea?
- "Plantear sobre una cosa tan seria un referendo
cuando la gente sobre la verdadera
operatividad y la realidad de la Unión Europea sabe muy poco".
Personalmente, eso me parece un
poco de matones. Desde luego  yo
apuesto más por prestar atención a los
motivos que pueden conducir a un país a
querer irse que por la política del
miedo. Pero... no nos desviemos. Bien,
Con todo esto, una pregunta que nos podemos
hacer es ésta ¿Se va a quedar a caso Reino  Unido
solo y aislado tras el Brexit?
Pues... cuidado con afirmar que sí porque
hay en marcha movimientos que pueden
cambiar el mundo tal y como lo conocemos.
Y desde luego el futuro tras el Brexit
no está ni mucho menos decidido.
A decir verdad ser parte de la Unión
Europea nunca ha motivado mucho a los
británicos.
De hecho, se unieron en 1973 y tan
sólo dos años más tarde ya celebraron
un primer referéndum para ver si se
quedaban o se marchaban
Ganó el sí pero desde entonces en
Downing Street, digamos que, han tenido
entre sus prioridades políticas
limitar el proyecto europeo a una
construcción económica pero no
política.
E incluso así, con matices. De hecho,
Reino Unido ha sido siempre un rara avis
dentro del club comunitario.
Por ejemplo, se han quedado fuera de
proyectos tan importante y tan
emblemáticos como el euro
o el espacio Schengen
Así que, llegados a este punto podemos
preguntarnos ¿qué se les pasa por la
cabeza a los británicos para tener tanta
animadversión a la Unión Europea?
Vale, es verdad,
los motivos son muchos pero uno de los
más importantes nos lo dejó ya claro
ni más ni menos que Winston Churchill,
atentos, en 1946 cuando pronunció su
famoso discurso de Zúrich, en el que dijo
dos cosas:
Primero, que apostaba por la
construcción de unos Estados Enidos de
Europa, pero.... eso sí,
entre los países de la Europa
continental. Vamos que apoyaba la
aventura pero que ellos no cogían el tren.
Y lo segundo que dijo es que ellos ya
tenían su propio club:
la Mancomunidad de Naciones, la Commonwealth
que en esa época ya se estaba montando
para dar acogida a todos los países que
se iban independizando del imperio.
Es decir, que los británicos soñaban con
tener su propio club y ese sentimiento
para muchos hoy no ha cambiado; sobre todo
respecto a algunas antiguas colonias
construidas a imagen y semejanza de la
Metrópoli.
Me explico, dentro del imperio británico
podíamos encontrar fundamentalmente dos
tipos de colonia: las colonias de
explotación, las más habituales, que
consistían en ocupar un territorio
para aprovecharse de sus recursos
naturales. En este tipo de colonias el
asentamiento de población blanca era
reducido y el desarrollo institucional
más bien escaso.
Por así decirlo, el Imperio Británico
pactaba con los gerifaltes locales y les
mantenía en el poder a cambio de su
cooperación.
Por otro lado estaban los dominios,
que recibían mucha población blanca y
reproducían el modelo de país que
había en casa, en la metrópoli.  Este es el
tipo de colonización que dio lugar a
los países más ricos como Canadá,
Australia o Nueva Zelanda. También a
Estados Unidos pero éste consiguió
independizarse muy pronto. El caso es
que es con estos últimos países con
los que los británicos se identifican
más, al fin y al cabo, son política,
social y culturalmente muy similares.
Y, ojo, ese sentimiento de afinidad e incluso
de hermandad es compartido también por
los habitantes de estos países ¿Queréis
una prueba? Por ejemplo, en la Segunda
Guerra Mundial, el ANZAK, el
"Australian and New Zealand Army Corps", un
ejército conjunto de Australia y Nueva
Zelanda combatió incluso en África y
en Europa,
apoyando directamente al ejército
británico
Pues bien, desde el principio uno de los
argumentos clave de los euroescépticos
fue precisamente que era más
importante centrarse en la Commonwealth
para crear una gran unión de
países anglosajones, especialmente con
estos que hemos visto.
Fijaros lo que dice Boris Johnson, uno de
los líderes del Partido Conservador que
más apoyó el Brexit y que hoy es, ni
más ni menos,
el Ministro de Exteriores del Reino Unido:
Pues bien, hoy ese sueño de muchos
británicos podría estar a punto de
cumplirse. Incluso ya tiene un nombre:
CANZUK.
Si os fijáis, CANZUK  es una palabra
compuesta por las iniciales de estos
cuatro países: Canadá, Australia, Nueva
Zelanda - New Zealand - y Reino Unido - United Kingdom.
Pues bien, lo cierto es que la unión
económica de estos países tiene mucho
sentido.
Ojo, unión económica y comercial no
política, porque aquí los anglosajones
son muy celosos de su soberanía. Pero...
¿Por qué digo que tiene sentido? Pues
porque los estudios demuestran que
cuando hay lazos culturales las
relaciones económicas son más grandes
Por ejemplo, dos países que comparten
idioma comercial hasta un 40% más entre sí.
Y si además de compartir idiomas
comparten también historia, entonces
comercian, atentos al dato, un 188% más
¡Qué se dice pronto!
Fijaros los países que forman el CANZUK,
que son todos muy ricos, suponen
aproximadamente el 7% de la economía
mundial, pues bien a pesar de ello
Estados Unidos que es muy similar y
comparte con ellos idioma, cultura
e historia, concentra en estos países el
25 por ciento de todas sus inversiones en el mundo
Pero.. ¿Qué importancia
tendría CANZUK? Pues, la verdad, es
que es un dimensiones son importantes:
hablamos de un grupo con 129 millones de
habitantes, que unidos serían la tercera
economía del planeta y también el
tercer mayor presupuesto militar.
Vamos, que este club anglosajón sería
un grupo bastante influyente y desde
luego Reino Unido sería su gran
referente.
Sí, vale, alguno diréis:
Enrique, la Unión Europea es muchísimo
más grande. Es verdad,
pero es que aquí no acaba la historia.
De llevarse a cabo este espacio de
libre comercio y libre movimiento de personas
la relación de CANZUK con Estados
Unidos sería muy especial, al fin y al
cabo, CANZUK está integrado por los
mayores aliados del país del country,
los perritos calientes y los cowboys.
De hecho, a día de hoy Estados Unidos ya
tiene en vigor tratados de libre
comercio con Canadá y Australia y su
actual presidente, Donald Trump, al que ya
sabéis todo el cariño que tenemos en
este canal
Se ha pronunciado a
favor de firmar muy rápido otro tratado con
Reino Unido.
Y, ojo, con las implicaciones que
esto tiene
si Londres consigue1 que el proyecto
CANZUK salga adelante y, además, consigue
firmar el tratado de libre comercio con
Estados Unidos, cosas que a día de hoy
parece muy factible, el mercado al que
tendrían acceso las empresas británicas
sería el doble de grande de lo
que es el mercado común de la Unión
Europea.
Vamos que, Reino Unido a medio plazo
incluso podría salir ganando
Y, ojo, porque como os venimos diciendo en
VisualPolitik hay que ver qué termina
ocurriendo con la negociación del
Brexit. Pero... aún hay más. CANZUK
tendría muchas opciones de cuajar
mejores relaciones y menores acuerdo con
aquellos países con los que comparten
lazos históricos como el resto de
miembros de la Commonwealth, por ejemplo,
Singapur, Malasia, La India, Sudáfrica...
en total 52 países y no nos olvidemos
tampoco de otros como Hong Kong o Israel
Vamos, que puede que sea un poco
excesivo hablar del regreso del Imperio
británico,
pero lo cierto es que la formación de
este gran club anglosajones podría
estar en marcha.
De momento existe apoyo social y
político más que de sobra para
llevarlo a cabo.
Amigos, las implicaciones de algo así
serían enormes y la verdad a muchos en
Bruselas se les quedaría cara de tontos.
Puede que por eso Theresa May, para
sorpresa de muchos haya decidido
negociar fuerte con la Unión Europea.
Por cierto, si aún no lo has visto no te
pierdas este vídeo donde nuestro amigo
Sebastián te cuenta que puede pasar con
la City tras el Brexit. Bueno, ¿tu que piensas?
¿Veremos la unión de todos
los pueblos anglosajones? ¿Tendrá éxito
Reino Unido con su nueva política
exterior tras el Brexit? ¿Deberíamos
los pueblos hispanos apostar por una
fórmula similar? No dudes en dejarnos tu
opinión en los comentarios,
y ya sabes si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante dale al botón de like y si
aún no lo has hecho ya no olvides
suscribirte al canal. Un saludo y hasta
la próxima